alors que le déconfinement et on sait
depuis hier en france la télé se met en
marche pour reprendre progressivement
ses programmes comme s'il existait avant
cette période de crise un chemin qui
sera long mais qui début de cette
semaine avec la reprise de plusieurs
tournages comme les émissions de jean
luc reichmann ou celle de nagui nous
reprenons les enregistrements de
n'oubliez pas les paroles
vous le voyez ça se passe en public
voyez sur cette image voilà yahia du
public les tournages de tout le monde
veut prendre sa place sur france 2
devrait reprendre dès jeudi avec une
première diffusion à l'antenne lundi des
délais à flux tendus pour permettre à la
chaîne de regagner des couleurs et de
relancer sa machine à audience et bien
entendu les tournages seront là encore
un peu différent de la version
originelle puisque 100 publique une
décision liée à la sécurité des
spectateurs présents sur les tournages
toutefois dans n'oubliez pas les paroles
nagui a eu l'idée de mettre dans les
gradins des ballons sur lesquels des
écrans reliés à skype permet de voir
quelques membres du public coucou
aliciens un coucou à la sont de vrais
téléspectateurs qui sont en visio et qui
vont pouvoir assister à cette émission
face à la difficulté de castet de
nouveaux candidats pendant le
confinement la production de tout le
monde veut prendre sa place a également
décidé de créer une session spéciale
master de champion en faisant
s'affronter entre eux des candidats
ayant déjà participé aux jeux de son
côté jean luc reichmann a déjà repris
les tournages depuis hier là encore sans
public mais avec eric le champion des 12
coups de midi qui n'a pas encore fini
son ascension avec 160 et une victoire
et 810 1244 euros de gains il dépasse en
cadeau le champion des champions et se
place en deuxième position sur le podium
en nombre de victoires
super idée ça fait du bien de voir des
gens même si c'est des ballons à aix
quatre mois je super idée faut innover
moi j'ai reproché à la télé de ne pas
avoir une vraie c'est l'arbre je trouve
ça vachement alors il ya aussi dans les
jeux vous le dis les physios les
démissions des fusées ce midi de jean
luc reichmann
elle a été diffusée aujourd'hui regardez
les 12 coups de midi il y avait paul par
exemple en skaï possible ou pas vous
l'avez regardé les deux comédies non moi
je regarde le week-end les 12 coups de
midi
d'accord bab boudir heures n'hésitez pas
à me faire un panier de ce que je sache
[Applaudissements]
posant voie d'eau à toutes vos jours à
tous je suis extrêmement heureux de vous
retrouver après des semaines un petit
peu particulière on tourne certes son
public ça ne vous a pas échappé mais
nous allons tout faire pour avoir une
ambiance maximale aux deux coups de
non-échange ça passe là je dis bravo à
passarella toutes nos missions qui se
sont débrouillés celui des
configurations d et voilà les données du
frais aux téléspectateurs avec avait
évidemment pas de public voilà mais
bravo bravo bravo nous voilà on a on a
un seul perdre une seule personne n'a
envie que l'amérique est vide tout se
passe bien kevin ça va mais je voulais
également dire merci à toi bats vois pas
ce que j'ai fait que c'est mental
continue d'animer nos soirées
dimanche éric un amoureux confinement si
la procédure là il y aura plus rien la
télé arabe est tous à minima voilà on
était à bercy c'est une vraiment dure
pas assuré et le ce soir tout le public
repart avec son fauteuil roulant
pas de place dans la raquette pas on va
tous et une estafette oui un petit
scandale dans dans les 12 coups de midi
c'est que eric le champion qui fait le
succès de évidemment démission de jean
luc reichmann chaque mini il était
confiné en bretagne oui il a fallu
qu'ils reviennent c'est plus de 100 km
donc ils ont demandé une dérogation
sayal belle somme pour un jeune des
regards désolé je suis d'accord alors là
là c'est allé voir ses enfants parce
qu'on n'a pas le droit
et on peut aller parce qu'un jeu je
trouve que vous êtes un peu dur et c'est
bien la première fois donc c'est d'aller
comme les dérogations par exemple pour
les gens qui doivent se déplacer dans le
cadre du travail
dans ce cas c'est comme un travail est
un travail voilà leur cadre du travail
je suis désolé oui madame oui c'est dans
le cadre absolument aucun du travail ils
avaient une seule l'autorisation pour
l'aller pas pour le retour ce qui fait
qu'il va rester confinées jusqu'à ce que
pendant quelques mois jean sensible
puisque à ce que des fêtes sans suivre
donc moi ça me choque mêlant absolument
pas en revanche s'il ya un vrai petit
scandale parce que pour le sétois ont
les fans de l'émission où il avait des
derniers des rediffusions avec le petit
paul oui le 12 mai c'était une date
anniversaire parce que c'est la date où
le petit paul avait découvert le pardon
le jeune paul avait découvert la
première étoile mystérieuse et les fans
moi moi pierre mas en dix ans mais que
c'est scandaleux
pourquoi il fait pas la rediffusion de
l'émission en anniversaire il ya un an
voilà il pourrait passer tous les midis
savais pas je suis avait pensé à en
parler au coup d'envoi
l'histoire des masses que tout ça c'est
pour moi c'est au-dessus un jeune au
dessus de tout ce qu'on a entendu
jusqu'à présent 1
je suis à deux doigts nous confiner la
france avec cette taille est un leurre
estonie ah oui mais on dit surpris
c'est fou merkel se passe des trucs là
bas je rejoins janvier quand même ballet
où je passe au mec qui doit aller voir
son fils ukip et qui doit avoir ses
enfants qu'il peut pas et là on lui dit
pour un jeu c'est un travail comme un
taff et même s'imposant de lesquin de
jeu ouais bien sûr maintenant les gains
de jeu sont imposables
c'est peut-être un travail et moi j'ai
gagné dix balles au morpion
j'en ai payé 3 sera versé 3 merci j'ai
gratté binta cnil à la lettone trois
balles 33 merci il ya une autre émission
qui a repris en plateau sans public
c'est l'émission de faustine bollaert ça
compense aujourd'hui j'adore cette
émission mais pourrait l'appeler ça
commence aujourd'hui lara sera c'est que
des gens qui viennent témoigner sur un
plateau pour son rachat
mais on aime bien ça cartonne c'est vrai
que c'est bon ça fait un million ces
roquettes enfin france 2 c'est vrai que
c'est un petit peu cette façon de
l'après midi de france 2 c'est c'est eh
ben c'est comme après midi de ses huit
ans c'est dur
si tu regardes barnola prévient de
france 2 si tu trouves pas une ou deux
veines avec un problème a été très
solide mentalement bonjour à tous et
bienvenue sur le plateau de ça commence
aujourd'hui c'est avec un immense
bonheur que je vous retrouve après ces
longues semaines d'interruption
alors évidemment on s'est adapté à la
situation avec un dispositif
exceptionnel pour le moment nos invités
qui vont témoigner aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau donc depuis chez eux on va
présenter les deux premières ce beau
soleil et ses palmiers ça se trouve ou
isabelle need mois à ça voilà c'est tout
bas voilà c'est l'impasse que faustine
bollaert
j'aime beaucoup aussi mais c'est vrai
que dans cette émission non plus c'est
pas non plus le feu
d'habitude c'est pas non plus quoi ya
pas de public dense et recommence au
laurie alors là alors là mais on ne peut
pas faire l'émission quoi les gars c'est
pas possible c'est le fire l'habitude
oui mais c'est une émission qui est basé
quand même sur l'empathie et l'empathie
ça passe aussi par le physique le regard
jemappes jean-michel un kleenex que
parfois ça pleure beaucoup c'est assez
lacrymal donc voilà donc il fallait
trouver quand même une façon de 2,2 de
pallier ce manque de ce manque
d'empathie sur le plateau et ils ont
quand même trouvé là quand même trouver
la juste nouveau stade bollaert était la
première reprendre la route des plateaux
dès la semaine dernière ça parce que je
sais que la semaine dernière et elle a
été sur la route de memphis